today we cancel
pink news which is a gay news outlet
based in the uk
um you'll be i'm sure shocked to
discover that the people who work for a
british gay news site called pink news
apparently are not fans of
yours truly me of all people i can't
imagine what sort of problem they could
have with me
in fact pink news has in recent years
written several outraged articles
attacking me for some of the things i've
said on this very show
i'm not ashamed to admit that each time
they publish an article like that i
openly weep as i read it
because all i want is for everyone to
like me that should be obvious to anyone
who listens to the show my main goal is
to say
really popular mainstream things it's
just that i'm bad at it
which brings us to the latest from pink
news the headline is daily wires matt
walsh compares
trans health care to pedophilia and nazi
science in disgusting rant
disgusting pink news i am a person with
feelings too you know
anyway the article says the daily wires
matt walsh has publicly compared trans
healthcare to experimentation
molestation abuse and rape in an episode
of his podcast the matt wall show
released on monday titled the evil
quacks mutilating our children
walsh went on a 20-minute rant about
gender ideology actually it was like 17
or 18 months
in fairness wall street thinks the use
of face masks to curb the spread of
crotovirus has created a society of
adults who fear breathing fresh air
said that trans youth should not receive
gender affirming healthcare because they
literally can't make good long-term
decisions
he continued quote this is also why we
say adolescents can't consent to sex
um dr johanna olsen kennedy wants to
undermine the legal scientific and
philosophical case against pedophilia
um and that's not a coincidence by the
way check back in 10 years or maybe
sooner and she'll be explaining with
equal passion why we must be tolerant
towards adult child
sexual relationships uh gender affirming
health care for trans youth is vital in
reducing mental health problems and
suicidal ideation has been backed by
every major major medical association
okay let's pause here for a moment
now most of what they've written so far
is true i did say
what they've quoted me as saying i i
said all of that because it's true i
don't apologize for it
and i don't wish to moderate or water
down my points at all i said what i said
and i meant it
um we run into problems though in that
last paragraph
where it says again gender affirming
healthcare for trans youth is vital in
reducing mental health problems and
suicidal ideation
and has been backed by every major
medical association
two major issues here first there's the
term gender affirming healthcare
and the second is there's the claim that
drugging and mutilating children is the
best way to stop them from killing
themselves
as for the first thing you may notice
how
there is no other context where
surgeries
and quote healthcare are administered to
affirm something
now to affirm means to state as a fact
or assert strongly
it can also mean offering emotional
support and encouragement
since when have you ever heard of an
emotionally supportive
surgery now you may say that all
cosmetic surgery sort of fits that bill
but nobody calls a nose job
a nose-affirming surgery and besides
gender ideologues would say that gender
affirming procedures quote-unquote
are not merely cosmetic
so the question remains when have you
heard of a medical procedure
that has the purpose of affirming when
have you heard of
medicine whose purpose is to make or
support an assertion in fact
when have you even heard of a therapist
whose primary goal is simply to affirm
that is encourage
or assert as fact whatever their
patients say to them
the goal of a therapist is supposed to
be oftentimes the opposite of that
and the goal of surgery and medicine is
to treat or heal an ailment
or an injury or a disease it's not to
affirm anything
now the gender ideologues aren't simply
misusing medicine
they're attempting to turn it on its
head they seek to fundamentally redefine
the very purpose of medicine just as
they seek to redefine sex and biology
and they seek to do this while
pretending that they aren't doing
anything radical or extreme at all
indeed they seek to do it while scoffing
at anyone who raises the slightest
objection
they've come along subverted millennia
of human experience wisdom and knowledge
and they insist not only that we allow
them to do it but that we don't even
raise a question about it and most
people seem willing to comply with those
demands i'm not and i never will be
never not ever i will continue to insist
on the truth
the truth that all of us and all people
everywhere have always known
up until 19 seconds ago one of those
truths is that there are only males and
females that's it that's all there are a
small minority of people who suffer
birth defects
that affect the appearance of their
genitalia which has nothing to do with
transgenderism anyway but still there
are only two sexes
no other human sexes have ever been
discovered or ever will be
another truth is that the purpose of
medicine is still despite what the
gender ideal
ideologues claim to treat and heal
so when a physically healthy young girl
is put on puberty blockers then hormones
and under breasts are chopped off
what physical ailment is being treated
what is the disease that these doctors
are trying to suppress or cure
you can't say that they're treating
gender dysphoria because gender
dysphoria is a mental condition
just like anorexia has a mental
condition you don't treat mental
conditions by altering the body to
coincide more closely with the patient's
delusional mental state
that's not how you heal mental illness
so again
what disease is being treated by
chopping off a girl's healthy breasts
womanhood is that the disease
well whether the gender ideologues will
say it out loud or not that is
how they see it that womanhood or
manhood is the disease and i would call
that pretty disgusting
speaking of disgusting the the emotional
blackmail that these people use
is not only disgusting but simply evil
they say that we must drug and mutilate
kids um
or else the kids will kill themselves
they say studies prove them right
they're lying these people are liars and
everything they say
everything should be ignored in fact
studies show
that suicide rates amongst among trans
people remain sky high
after surgery but that's not even the
point the point is that we just now
started doing this kind of thing to
thousands of kids all at once
when the when the gender ideologues
start talking about all the studies
proving the efficacy and safety of their
procedures
you know they're lying because there
can't have been any reliable long-term
studies on this subject there hasn't
been a large enough sample size to study
yet
this current crop of children they are
the guinea pigs
the mad scientists are running
experiments on them
they're one big test group the
assumption the claim
the hope is the assertion is that
drugging them and chopping off their
body parts
will work out well in the long term
there is no data to support that
assumption
there can't be and any sane person's
common sense and moral intuition
militates against those assumptions
well maybe i'm wrong a little bit there
was one long-term study that comes to
mind one experiment conducted decades
ago whose results can now be observed as
i've mentioned before john money
tested these gender theories that he
came up with on two young boys in the
1970s
and how did that go well both of them
went on to kill themselves
so those were the long-term results
and these are the facts pink news
doesn't want to hear the facts
they don't want you to hear the facts
either which is why they ended their hit
piece this way quote
walsh's social media posts about the
podcast on facebook youtube and twitter
remain live
and his podcast remains available
through apple podcasts despite each
platform having policies against hate
speech
he also remains verified on twitter
facebook and youtube
pig news has approached facebook youtube
twitter and apple for comments
well of course they have they know their
position is indefensible
they know it they know everything i'm
saying is 100 obviously true
they have no counter argument no
rebuttal none nothing
all they could do is run to the
principal's office and try to get me
suspended or expelled
and maybe they'll succeed eventually i
don't know
but that won't change the truth and it
won't stop me from speaking it
and it also won't stop me from saying to
pink news you're cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content